we could raise revenue and save Social
Security by simply asking the rich to
finally pay their fair share and there's
nothing new or radical about that what's
radical is forcing one generation to pay
for the retirement of another there's a
major misconception about social
security the US government isn't saving
your money in fact they're not saving
any money at all the government
immediately takes in your money and then
pays it out to predominantly older
wealthier Americans even worse the trust
fund is set to be depleted by 2033. this
is a government-run Ponzi scheme and
Americans should have the choice to opt
out in 1940 160 people paid into social
security for every one collecting
benefits today that number has dwindled
to two to one and the government doesn't
owe you a dime because the Supreme Court
ruled Social Security payments are not a
contractual right they can be reduced or
eliminated at any time Social Security
is anything but secure and it's
certainly not worth saving so let's
scrap the program entirely and let
Americans say for their own retirement